この悩みのない
苦しみのない
生き方
と無常という
お釈迦様の教えを
どうつなげるかということなんです。
だいたい
仏教を本から読む人々は
無常という言葉を聞いた途端
「これは暗い教えだなあ」と
すぐ思うんですね。
「ああ、無常だ」と
なぜならば世の中に
普通にある宗教ならば
すごく永遠な
天国か
そういう何かを約束してくれるし
特に、例えばキリスト教だったら
Heavenですか、天界ですか
そういうものを約束してくれるんです。
仏教だけはなんでいきなり無常だと
避けられないものだと始まるんですかと
暗いのではないかと
思うかもしれません
そんな暗いものを考えたら
どんどん人生も暗くなってしまって
悩みを無くすどころか、無い悩みまで生まれてくる
のではないかと思うのかもしれません
じゃあ、それはどういうことかと考えてみましょう
この無常というのは
残念ながらいくら嫌だとおもっても
真実なんです
私たちが嫌だといったとしても
世の中の道理は変わるわけではないんですよ
それは真理であって真実なんです
なにものも
止まって、変化しないで
一定した状態に
あるわけがないのです
何を見ても
変化して、変化して変わっていくのです
それは毎日見えているのです
それを嘘だと言うならばどうしようもないのです
治ることができないのです
嫌だと思ってしまったら
嫌ということではなくて
世の中は無常なのです
それは真実なのです
じゃあ、なんで我々が無常を知っていれば幸福になりますか
今日はお釈迦様の
ある言葉からお話をしたいと思います
Sabbe saṅkhārā aniccā ti
Yadā paññāya passati
Atha nibbindati dukkhe
Esa maggo visuddhiyā
（Dhmmapada 277）
こちらの意味は
「sabbe」というはじめの言葉の意味は
一切すべてのものは
全ての物事は
現象は
つまり、世の中にあるすべてのものは
「sabbe saṅkhārā」
存在すべてを意味します
「saṅkhārā」ということは仏教の用語を知ってる方々は
しってるかもしれません。
全ての現象、全ての物事は
「aniccā ti」
無常であると
「yadā paññāya passati」
「yadā」というのはいつかという意味なんですね
「paññāya」
智慧で
智慧をもって
「passati」
観るならば、観ることができるならば
いつか智慧をもって観られるならば
何を観るんですか
全ての物事は無常であると
３行目の「atha」はそのとき
これちょっとひっくり返して読むんです
「dukkhe」　苦しみに対して
「dukkhe」　というのは苦しみに対して
「nibbindat」
嫌悪ですか、嫌う
諦めると
苦しみは「もう嫌だ、結構だ」
と思ってしまうのです
「esa maggo visuddhiyā」
これは道である
「visuddhiyā」清らな状態、いわゆる涅槃、解脱なんです
悟りの境地なんです
清浄な境地と
理解したほうがいいのです
清浄な境地に至るための
道はこれです
あっちこっち言葉を回さないと
（日本語の）文章にはならないのですが
パーリ語のお釈迦様の言語は、そういうものなのです
結構、回って読まないと
まあ、そんなふうに
内容をしゃべると
授業みたいになって
ここでお釈迦様がおっしゃっているのは
「すべてのものは無常である」と知りなさいと
それを知ったならば
それで苦しみを嫌になってしまうのだと
心が清らかになるのだと
いわゆる苦しみのない心が生まれるということなんです
お釈迦様がすべては無常だといったのは
我々に何か
恨みがあっていっているわけではないのです
我々の苦しみを無くしてほしいのだから
悩みのない苦しみのない
心を作りたかったんだから
それを強調して
「諸行無常」は日本で有名なフレーズなんです
「Sabbe saṅkhārā aniccā」というのは
「諸行無常」という
まあ皆さま覚えていらっしゃるでしょう
それはパーリ語だったら「Sabbe saṅkhārā aniccā」
ですからいくらか無常について考えてみましょう
私がよくいうのは皆様方が
まあ、大体世の中の人間が
大変、結構楽しく生きているのですよ
で、たまに人が
苦しくて悩んでいるかもしれませんが
大体その他の大勢の方々は
まあ、楽しく頑張って生きているのです
で、悲しい苦しいと思う人も
完全に人生が悲しく、苦しいわけではなくて
結構、楽しく過ごしているのです
そういうことではなくて
それだけではなくて
我々はだいたい楽しみを求めて頑張っているのです
いつでも
「これよりなにか楽しいことはないんですか」と
「これより幸福なことはないのですか」と
幸福・楽しみというもの
探し求めて努力して生きているんです
それは大体皆さま自分の経験で
まあ、わかっていることだとおもいます
完全に苦しいわけではないのだから
その「楽しみ」は
なんであるかと
今日は勉強してみましょう
その「楽しみ」は「無常」そのものなのです
全然私たちは気が付かないのです
無常だからすごい楽しいんですよ
無常だから苦しいのではなくて
で、結構皆様方音楽好きでしょう
音楽というのは無常の象徴みたいなものなのです
一秒間でも音はかなり変化するのです
そこで若い人であればあるほど
その音の
変化が早いほど
美しい音楽だと思っちゃうんですね
年を取ってくると少々
ゆっくり
音の変化が起こったほうがいいと
思ったりするかもしれません
ちょっと想像してみてください
ある人がこれから演奏しますと
楽器の一つのNOTEだけ弾いたとしましょう
ピアノでもいいしバイオリンでもいいし
ただ、ひとつのNOTEだけずっと１時間くらい弾いているのだと
そうするとそれほど音の変化がないんですね
どう思いますかね？
もし聞いたこと経験したことがなければ
自分の家に帰って、もし楽器があるならば
どんな音でもいいのです
どんな音程のどんなオクターブの音でも
一つの音
ドだったらドだけずーっと
やってみてください
どうなるのですかと
それは音楽になるんですかね？
その場合は
そのときはものすごく苛立ってくるんですよ
それよりは車の雑音のほうがましと思っちゃうんですよ
すごく嫌な音なんですよ
楽器の音をみんな好きなんですが
同じ音をずっと繰り返すと
あれほど嫌な、嫌いなものはないのです
これはなんですかね？
次は、さっさと指を動かして
ある一定の法則によって音を変えてみてください
すぐ気持ちよくなるのです
だから、音楽は無常の象徴なんです
だから面白いのです
皆さまがた映画を観るでしょう
映画でも大体人気があるのは
一コマ一コマ早く動く
ものなのです
２－３分かけて俳優か女優が誰か一人だけ
じっと待って、しゃべりっぱなしだったら
ものすごいつまらなくてあくびが出るのです
そうじゃなくて、ありとあらゆるアクションがあって演技があって
さっさと画面が動いていると
観ていられるんですね
テレビみているときでも
一人か二人が座って、まあくだらない話を
ずっと延々としゃべっているとチャンネルを変えるんじゃないですか
だから楽しみの
秘密はそこにあるんですよ、変化にあるんです
それは真実なんです
よくあることですよ、日本で
４月になると
皆の頭がくるっちゃうんですね
桜の花が咲くんだから
大勢でいって
花見といって酒を飲んでカラオケ歌って
大変楽しんでいるのです
いつだって花はあるのだけども
なんであの時だけはあんなに
頭が狂ったように、お祭りをするんですかね
花屋さんに行けばいつでも花があるのだから
なんで花屋さんにいって
花見のお祭りをやらないんですかね
もっと立派な花がいっぱいあるのに、高価な花が
あれはなんですかね
はっきり自分の心に聞いてみてください
花屋さんの花はいつでもあるんです。だから面白くないのです。
いつでもあるのだから
花屋さんでも自分の店の前でちょっとした
催し物をしてくれればみんなでやってくれれば
ありがたいことでしょう
なぜならば店の宣伝になるのだから
でも普通の人間にとっては面白くない
いつでもそこに花があるのだから
でも桜はそんなもんじゃないんですよ
一年に一回だけ、それも２－３日で散ってしまう
だから面白いんですよ
だから感激するんです、感動するんです
皆様方じーっと桜の花をみたことがありますか
みてください。面白くない花ですよ。
よくみると
単純で
それでも
感情として「面白くない」というのは
もしかすると私だけかもしれません
それは瞬間に咲いて
すぐ消えるものだから
面白いか面白くないか、単純な花かそうでないか
それを見ている暇がないのですよ
さっさとみておかなくては
だから、そこは無常であって
国民的に我々に喜びをつくってくれるんです
我々といっても私はこの国の国民ではないのだけれども
皆様に
国民的な喜びを
湧かせてくれる出来事なのです
わけ（理由）は
無常だからなのです
なんで緑の葉っぱのお祭りをやらないんですかね
桜の花よりもっと大勢に
緑の葉っぱがあるんですから
あれはいつでもあるから面白くないのです
紅葉はなんでそんなにありがたがるのですかね
一時的にしかないからなんです
いつでも葉っぱが真っ赤になっているのであれば
全然どうってことはないのです
そういう葉っぱもありますよ、一年中赤いとかね。
日本でもあるとおもいますけどね。まあ熱帯の
地方だったら一年中赤いとか
そのように色づいたおしゃれな植物もあります
それは別に面白くないのです。毎日見ているのだから。
だから我々の幸福の秘密
安らぎの秘密は
無常という現象にあること
それは明確な事実なのです
そこで人間から見れば
一番面白いのは人間の中で誰をみているときですかね
例えば、小さな子供がいる
そこに８０歳のおじいさん、おばあさんがいるとする
我々普通の人間の目はどちらにいくのですかね
おじいさん、おばあさんをじっと見ているのがたのしいですかね
全然楽しくないのです
それよりは子供のほうをみるのです
これはなんでしょうか
子供というのはじっとしてないのです
ちょっと放っておけばなにをするかわからない
どんな危険なことをするかわからない
それで瞬間でも
同じ状態にいない、動くこと動くこと動くこと
やることなければ
泣き出しちゃうし
なんかあったらすごく泣いていた子が
瞬間に笑ってしまう
えらい心が変わるんですよ
だけどおじいさんかおばあさんが
ただ、じっとすわってぼけーとしているのだから
動かないのだから面白くないのです
誰にも若者に対してなかなか
なんで興味があるかというと
若者というのは結構変わるんですよ、毎日毎日
明日になったら何をするかわからないほど
大人からすれば心配で仕方がないのだけれども
それはそうなんですよ。かえって面白いのです
元気で
ですから、よく覚えておいてほしいのです
この無常ということは
幸福を作ってくれるんですよ
楽しみを作ってくれるんです
ですから無常は嫌だというのは
もう、とんでもない
とんでもない悪人ですよ
人間の幸福は嫌いといっているのかもしれません
無常は万歳といわなくてはならない
万歳といわなくても、無常は確実に事実としてあるのだから
だから無常をつかめた人が
そこに
幸福をつかめるのです
いとも簡単なことなのです
ただ、心の底から
全ては無常であると
じっと認めること
心の心底から
本心から
嘘はいけませんよ
偽善はいけません
では次の問題
無常はわかりますけど
全てのものは無常とわかりますけど
でも我々は悩んでいるのだと
でも我々には苦しみがあるのだと
あれは一体なんでしょうかと
それは世の中では人間、偽善というんですか
うその
偽りの
偽善者なんですよ
嘘をついているのです
無常がわかっていないのです
ただ、「わかったわかった」というだけで
心の中でわかってないんです
だから苦しみがあるんです
我々の心の構造
どこかおかしいのです
それを治せば問題がないのです
そのおかしいところはこういうことなのです
無常
のなかで生きていて
無常を楽しんで
いながらも、無常そのものを
なくそうと思っているのです
それでそれはできない
それで苦しくなってしまう
といってもわからないでしょう。では、わかるように説明します。理解できるように。
この前もこちらで子供の教育に対して講演しましたけど
子供に対して悩んでいる
両親がいるんですね
不思議なことに、この世の中に
いつ悩んでいるかというと
子供というのは中学、高校の間に
なると、両親が悩み始めてしまう
なんで、それまでは悩まないのですかね
それまでは子供というのは小さくて
独立できないのです
やっぱり徹底的に
親に依存しなくては生きていられないのです
世の中が大きくて自分がすごく小さくて
だから仕方なく嫌々ながら
親が言うことを聞くのです
学校がいうことをよく聞くのです
どんどん足も手も伸びてきて
体も大きくなってくると
同時に世の中のことを知るようになってくると
独立しようとするんです
その時はそれをやめろと親が頑張るのです
子供の成長をなんとかして押さえつけて
ストップかけようとするのです
それできるんですか？
それだったら化学的に子供を
なんか変化しないように
プラスティックの何かにいれて
箱に入れておいたほうがいいのです
毎日ご飯を食べているのだから変化しているのですよ
それは自分の気持ちのいいときだけの変化は認めるのです
赤ちゃんがやっと立ちましたと写真までとるんです
立ちましたと
それでまあ楽しくて仕方がないのです
あれは変化なんです
立てなかった赤ちゃんが立ったということは
両親にとっても大変な大喜びで
楽しくてしょうがない
立った赤ちゃんがやっと一歩二歩歩いたら
もう、歩いた歩いたと
旦那さんがもしアメリカで仕事をしているならば
アメリカまで電話をかけて
写真も送ってくるのです
送っちゃうんです。それくらい喜んじゃうのです
無常そのものが
歩いたと。一歳になったと
ああだこうだとか。幼稚園に入りましたと
神社参りに行ったとか
それは全部無常を示すものなんですよ
七五三とか
そこであの人たちが
中学生くらいになると
「ああ、大変悪い子になりました」と、いうことを聞かないのだと
家庭内で
暴力をふるっているのだと
冗談じゃないのですよ
いままで変化をみてきて
楽しくて楽しくて
でも「そこまでです」と
いっているのと同じです
あなたはいつまでも１０歳くらいの子でいなさいと
そういう
病気じゃないんですかね、人間というのは
ありっこないでしょうに
男の子だったら
１４－１５歳になったらひげも生えるし
声も変わるし
でっかい大男になっちゃうし
女の子だったら１４歳になったらすごい成長して
普通の女の子の状態になりますから
親の言うことを聞かない
なんでその無常は楽しめないのですかね
いつでも物事は変化しているのに
なんでわがままをしようと思うのですかね
それが苦しみの元なのです
それでまた想像してください
子供というのは
大体、三歳、四歳、五歳というのは一番かわいい
いくらか自立していて
いくらか自分に依存していて
いくらか自分のことを自分でやって
残りは全部親に任せていて
それはもう子供の成長からみて
大人から見れば一番かわいい時期なのです
自分にとって今の子供の状態が一番かわいいのだから
そのままでいてほしいと
もし願ったところで
もし神様でもいたならば
「では、あなたの願い事を叶えてあげます」と
成長をストップさせてもらったらどうなるんですかね
何年たってもこの状態だったら
えらいことでしょ、それだったら。気持ち悪くて。
例えば、世の中にはときどきいるのですね、ホルモンの
関係で体が成長しない
４０歳になっても背が伸びない
顔を見たら年寄りに見えますが
後ろからみたら子供のようにみえるとか
あれで喜ぶ親がいるんですかね
私の子は成長しないでよかったと
ホルモンのバランスがとれなくて
成長ホルモンがでなくてよかったと思う人がいるんですかね
それでまた悩んでしまうのだから
我々はあまりにも
無知なんです
あまりにもばかばかしいのです
もう一つ例を申し上げると
例えばお金が無い人がいる
お金がないんだから困っちゃったなあと
それでいくらかお金を儲けなくちゃいけない
そして努力する
努力するとどんどんお金が入ってくるでしょう
それは無常だからお金が入ってくるのですよ
そうでなければ入りません
自分がいろんなことをする
そのためにはほかの人のお金が自分に回ってくる
その分は楽しいのですよ
お金が回ってくる分だけは
一旦回っているお金は
止まっているわけではないのですよ
また流れていくのです
自分が服を買わなくてはいけない、家賃を払わなくてはならない
いろいろご飯を食べなくてはいけないのだから
それでここに流れてきたお金が
ここからまた流れていくのです
その分は嫌だと思っちゃうんです
あれば正気といえるんですかね
そんなわがままはきかないのです
法則というのは
ですからそれはそのまま
認めておけば、知っておけば
お金が入ったのだからといって偉そうに舞い上がることもなければ、無くなったとしてもどうってことはない
そのときそのとき堂々と
幸福で
生きていられるんですよ
で、我々ご飯食べるでしょう
ご飯食べるとおいしいのです
あれ、なんでおいしいんでしょうか
ご飯に入っている成分が
溶けちゃって舌に触れるのだからです
だからおいしいのです
もし、ご飯食べた時に
無常なご飯ではないのだと
思ったら
おなかに入れたらそのままなのです
無常が無ければご飯は消化しませんし
栄養は吸収できないのだから
一回食べれば一生終わります
ご飯食べておいしいというのは無常だからなんですよ
朝ごはんも食べる、昼ご飯も食べるのだと
また夜も食べるのだと
三回楽しめるのではないですか
もし早く消化するんだったら
四回、五回でも食べられるのだから
その分楽しめるんじゃないですか？
やっぱり無常のほうが楽しいのです
わからないのは
なんでこの世の中で我々は困ったり悩んだり
しているんでしょうか
それは例えばこういうことでしょう
ある人に出会う
出会って
この人はすごく性格がいいと
自分が気に入りましたと
いい友達になりましょう
その日はその人と一緒に
お付き合いをする、いい友達として
付き合いをする
自分がその人の
性格の一部を観たのだから
また他の日にその同じ人に会う
会ったところで我々は
例えば一週間あとであったならば
一週間前に
会った友達に
友達に会いたいのです
まあ、ちょっとややこしくなりましたけども話が、例えば
今日、三時にあったひとに
また来週も会いましょうと
来週も会います。来週も三時に
その時私たちの心の中で
先週
先週の三時にあったときのその人に
会いたがっちゃうんです。
そんなことはありっこないのですよ
一週間たったのだからその人は完全に
変化しているのです
時空関係のなかで
ですから会うのは全くの別人なのです
そこで二度目にあったら
いろいろ関係がややこしくなるのです
それほど喜びがなくなっちゃうんです
会うたびに過去の人に会いたがってしまいますから
会うたびに関係はよくなるどころかどんどん悪くなっちゃうんです
そういうことなんです。夫婦の間でケンカとかあるのは。
2人とも頭の中がくるっているのですよ。
頭の中で作っているイメージがあって
そのイメージにぴったり
会う人を探しているのです
だから奥さんが自分の旦那さんのことを考えるかといえば本当は
実際に生きている生身の旦那さんのことではないのですよ
考えているのは
頭の中で妄想している
とんでもない概念に対してなのです
本人とあわないのだから
そこでトラブルが起こるのです
男性の場合も同じなのです
実際に生きている
変化している自分の
その瞬間、その瞬間に
態度が変わる自分の奥さんを観ないで
心の中で頭の中で
描いている奥さんを観ようとするのです
そうするとお互いに
楽しく幸福に生きていくことができないのです
男の人はよくいうのです「女というのはよく変わるものだ」と
それ女だけですかね
男も一秒間以内で
百回くらい変わるんですよ
その、いつでも変わるということがわかったら
二度と同じ瞬間はないということが
わかるんですよ
同じ人には二度と会わないのです
AさんがBさんにあったというのならば
また二度とAさんはBさんと会わないのです
次に会うのは
Aさんが変化した他の人であって
Bさんが変化した他の人なのです
ですから初対面なのです
初対面でケンカするひとがいないでしょうに
いくらなんでも
大変乱暴な
人であったとしても初対面ではケンカはしません
初対面ではよろしくという感じですから
ですから、我々はいつでも初対面なのです
人間同士だけではなくて
世界も全部
ずっと変わっているのです
ですから、お釈迦様がいうのは
頭が悪いことを治してください
頭が悪いことを治したら「paññā」
智慧が生まれるのですよ
paññāが無い人にお釈迦様はすごく丁寧な
言葉で一言いっているのです。愚か者だと。
世の中の人間は
無知で愚か者だと。
狂っているのだと。これはお釈迦様が使っている言葉なのです。
私が使っているわけではないのです
よく考えるとそうではないかなと
我々は無常を楽しんでいて
無常に逆らおうとしている
全てのものは無常だと
徹底的に知っていると頭の悪いところが治ってしまうのです
そうするとなんでもかんでも初対面で
楽しくて
すごくわくわくして生きていられるんです
いとも簡単ですよ
すぐ瞬間にその状態を作ることができるのです
すぐ今の瞬間から我々は覚悟を決めて
やっぱり絶対無常だと
望みはしませんと
決めておけばその瞬間から
何の苦しみもなくなってしまうのです
よく人間泣くんですねえ
旦那さんが亡くなった、奥さんが亡くなったと
親戚が、おばあちゃんが亡くなったとか
なんというバカかと思いますよ
もし、おばあちゃんが全然亡くならなかったらどうなるんですかと
おかしくてしょうがないのですよ、人間が泣いているのをみると、僕にとっては
たまに病院で手も足も何も動かない
末期状態になってギリギリのところで
それでも亡くなっちゃったら泣くんです
なんで泣くかとわからない
いたら大変なんですよ
自分ではなくて、本人の立場で見てください
足も不自由で手も不自由で耳も聞こえない
目も不自由でご飯も喉を通らなくて
ベッドから降りられないとか
その人の身になって考えてください。
その人が亡くならないでずーっといたならば
だから続くということはいいことではないのです
そこに苦しみがあるんです
確実に
我々はよく
無常に逆らって、泣いたり
悲しがったりしているんです
例えば、自分にすごい親しい誰かが亡くなっちゃったら
あー亡くなったと、これからどうしますか？と
すぐ考えればいいんです。自分は生きているのだから。
それだけで物事はおわるのです
そういうことで無常というのは
この世のこの上ない
幸福の話なのです
なおかつこれは真実なのです
そこで私はよくいう言葉がありまして
「無常すなわち存在」
という言葉を私が使っているのです
よく私はその言葉を使うのです。無常
すなわち存在
「無常イコール存在」と。
それを呪文のように覚えておいてください
これはもう、これ以上素晴らしい呪文はないのです
幸福をつくってくれます
瞬間に奇跡的に自分を幸福にしてくれます
オームとかへんてこりんなわけのわからない
得体のしれない呪文を唱えても
なんの役にも立たないのです
南無妙法蓮華経とかいろいろあるんですね
なにでか人間というのは呪文が好きで
こういうのは本物の呪文なんです。無常、
すなわち、存在
意味が分かれば
例えばここに光があるのですね
蛍光灯とかスポットライトとかいろいろ光があるのです
光というのはずっと流れては消え
流れては消えるものなのですよ
電気が流れて来て蛍光灯や
ライトに入ると電気がなくなって
熱に交換されて光に交換されて
それから光が出ていって消えてしまう
だから光があるんですよ
ずーっと消えていくのだから光があるのです
もし電気がずっと流れて
来ない場合は、ライトはストップ
もしこの部屋に入った光が
そのまま止まったならばどうなるんですか
そうすると何一つ見えないのです
全部光でもう
あふれて
まぶしくて、何にも見えなっちゃう
冗談じゃないんです
光が出て消えていく
また二度と戻らない
だから我々に光がある
存在がある
変化しなければ何もない
これを見ても同じことなんです
私の音はここにあり、すぐに消えちゃうのです
違うものが生まれてきて
アンプからまた違うものが生まれてきて
スピーカーからでてくるのです
それは全く違うものなのです。私の声ではないのです。
だから私の声は届くのです
無常でなければ何にもないのです
車をみてください
車に燃料をいれる
そしてエンジンをかけてどこかにいく
そこで大変楽になっているのです
でも同時に車は
老化するんです
もし車が老化してほしくなければ
全然動かさないでプラスティックの
カバーにでも入れて
シールしておけばいいのです。油を中にいれて
それでは使い物にはならないのです
太陽をみてください。太陽はずっと燃えっぱなしで
そこで熱やらエネルギーやら我々に
入ってくるのではないかと
何を観たとしても物事が
変化することによって我々は生きている
それは宇宙的な真理なんです
止まったら、変化が止まったら、ものが
消えちゃうんです
存在しない
具体的にいえば、「無常すなわち存在」という言葉はね
そんなに大胆に考えなくても自分から
考えましょう
私は存在しているんですよ
別にまあ皆様に聞く必要もないのだけども
私は自分が存在しているとおもっているのです
皆さまは自分が存在していると思っているのです
あれ、どういうことかというと常に変化しているからなのです
一個の細胞から生まれた皆様方は
どんどん（変化して）この状態になったんです
何か悪いことがありますか？変化する過程で
もしその変化がちょっとでもおかしくなったら
皆さま病気だなんだというのですよ
例えば皆様の胃袋が
激しく活動して変化しているのです
それなにか悪いのですか？
悪くないのです。
活動しなかったならば困るのだから
もし胃袋が停止しましたと
私は今日から無常は嫌だから
「常」のつねの状態になりますと。永遠の状態になりますと
そうすると石みたいになっちゃって、ダイヤみたいになって
もう変化しないのだから
もう、冗談ではないのです。それで人は死んじゃうんですよ。ご飯が食べられないのだから
何も悪くはないのですよ、無常で。
血液は流れていくわ
いつでも酸素は吸ってるわ
外の物質ですよ体に入るのは
入って体からいくらか出ていって
だからいつでも物々交換しながらいるんですよ
それがなんで悪いと思うのですかね
その中でみんな、何かどこかに
悩みを作っちゃうのです。
これは作る悩みは全部おかしいのです
それは無常に逆らうことなのです
誰かが亡くなって嫌だとか
あるいは
何に悩んでいるか私にはわかりませんが
聞いたとしてもくだらない悩みですけどね
あまり個人的には聞きたくないのです。
「あれ、そんなことで悩んでいるのですか」と
と思いますからね
あまり聞きたくもないのです。悩みというのは。
上司にいろいろなことをいわれるのだとか
あれで何で悩むんですかね？それで
言いたい放題いっちゃえばいいんだから
あれで、悩んじゃうんです、よく
何故か自分の頭の中で
ものすごいくだらない妄想概念があるんです
自分に対して人は
親切な言葉をしゃべるべきだよと
冗談じゃないですよ。自分というのはいつも変化するんだから
例えば、自分が二十歳くらいの女性だったら
すごく若くて美しくて
誰からも親切に
アプローチされますよ
その概念をもって八十歳になって
同じく自分に対して
親切にかわいがってもらえると思ったら
それはないのです。自分が変化しているのだから
だから月曜日に上司に褒められた人が
火曜日には叱られるんですよ、別に
ずっと褒めてほしいと思っちゃったら
それは、無常に逆らうこと
というくだらないことで悩むのです
特に子供のことで悩んでいる両親というのは
とんでもない人間なんですよ
悩む必要ないんだから。子供というのは変化するんだから
自分の希望通りいかないのだから
自分の希望、例えば、変化を認めたとしても
「いや変化は認めますけど、
「私の希望通りに変化してないんだ」と
それだったら両親が悪いんです
ですから、この
私たちはずっと変化していく
それで楽しがってる
ですから
これからも変化を楽しまなくてはいけないのです
若い時だけ楽しがっていて、「ああ、そろそろ中年になった」と
「ああ、やれやれ」と思って苦しむのは
それはバカもいいところですよ
もう、中年だから中年を楽しもう
もう老年になったのだから
それでまあ
老人には老人なりの生き方があるではないかと
それで年取ったところで
若いうちはよかったとか
若い時のことばっかり
考えているんですね
問題は頭なんです
頭の中にいろんな妄想概念がある
たまにこの若い時はすごく贅沢を
した人々がいて
あとで財産がなくなっちゃって
お金が無くなったりする場合があるんです
それで、その状態で生きていけばいいんだけども
その時は人からお金を借りてでも
贅沢したがっちゃうんです。それでさらに
堕落してひどいめにあっちゃうんです
それはなぜかというと頭の中に自分が
おいしいものしか食べたことが無いんですよと
だから今日もおいしいものが食べたいのだよと
あれはいい加減な生き方なんです
それはその時、今は今と
ちゃんとベッドでなければ寝ませんよとか
もし山の中に
遭難したら木の上でも
寝ちゃえばいいし。「今日は木の上だ」と
「明日は布団のなかだ」と
そういう風な生き方で
瞬間瞬間の生き方は
幸福な生き方なんです
だから無常という概念は
すごく明るくみるべきなのです
無常だからよかったんだ
病気になったときのことを考えてください
もし病気になったときは無常でよかったのではないのですか？
病気だから薬飲んだらすぐ
薬の成分が体に入ったら病気が飛んじゃうでしょ？
もし体に入ったウィルスが
体を自分の永住の住処にしたならばどうなるんですか？
冗談じゃないでしょう？
やっそれは追っ払えるし
薬で抑えられるし、それで健康的になるのだから
その分だけ見ているんですね我々は
病気になったときだけ無常はありがたいのだと
でも健康のときは無常はありがたくないのだと
でも健康なときも無常でなければ健康じゃないのだから
例えばスポーツをして体力をつける
無常でなければ体力はつきませんし
次の問題は我々が悩むこと
病気になることに悩む
お金が無くなることに悩む
嫌にな人に付き合うことに悩む
好きな人と離れることに悩む
年取ることに悩む
死ぬことに悩む
それも
無常の過程で
必然的にあることなのです
そのときに悩むのは
例えば、年取っていくと
「ああ、嫌だなあ」と「年取るのは嫌だなあ」と
じゃあ年取らなかったらどうなるんですか？
大変危険でしょうに
ですから、年取るほうが年取らないより
一番ありがたいのです。
そうでなければ何の楽しみもないのだから
年とっていつか消えてしまうのです
消えるのだからわれわれ
皆この世の中で死んじゃうでしょう
だからなんとか我慢できるんじゃないですか
考えてください
嫌な上司とずっと付き合わなくてはいけないのだと。一万年くらいでも
嫌な自分の旦那と
旦那さんであろうが
一億三千万年付き合わなくていけないのだとしたら
冗談じゃないんですよ
この世の中にしても
ずっといなくてはいけないのだと
そういう羽目になったら
それこそ不幸なんです
どんな嫌な人であろうが
一時間くらいは我慢できるでしょう
付き合うときは
じゃあ、三十分だったらもっと我慢できるでしょう
「ああ三十分だったらなんとかできます」
じゃあ、十分だったらもっと
我慢できるし
一分だったらさらに簡単であるし
じゃあ、嫌な人と一秒間付き合ってくださいといったら
なんてことはないでしょう
すごく楽しくそのときは物事が終わっちゃいますから
だから本当は、我々は
一秒間ではなくて瞬間しか会わないのですよ
瞬間しか会わない
だから究極の楽しみがあるはずなんです
それを発見してください
だから無常をとことん観察して
ヴィパッサナー瞑想でもって、心の中から
ありとあらゆる現象が生まれて消えて
生まれて消えてい〔のが観える〕のです。耳にいろんな音が入る。
入る音が消えていってしまう。
ある音によって気持ちよくなっちゃう
ある音によって気持ち悪くなっちゃう
ある音によってがっかりする
ある音によってびっくりする
ある音にはイライラする
それらは一つも止まりません
イライラしても次の音は気持ちいいとか
次の音はすごく落ち着くとか
そのようにありとあらゆる現象が
音にしても目に入るものにしても
ずっと静かになって自分の
心臓の音を聞いてみてください
ドクンドクンと音がしているのだから
同時に体中
ずっと血液が流れて消えていくんですよ
全部瞬間瞬間
そういう風にとことん無常を
とことん無常を感じるんですよ
感じれば感じるほど、どんどんどんどん
束縛が消えて行っちゃうんです
苦しみを諦めちゃうんですよ
苦しみっていうのは
「結婚しなくちゃ」「家を立てなくちゃ」
「仕事をしなくちゃ」
「ああしなくちゃ、こうしなくちゃ」
そんなものは全部苦しみなんですよ
希望は全部苦しみなんですよ
ですから
まあ、諦めちゃう。そんなものは、その時のことだと
諦めて、心はすごく
清浄な状態になるのです
ただ、なんのことなく
瞬間瞬間幸福で楽しんで
生きていられるようになります
ということで話はそれほど
まとめられませんでしたけど
一言、最後に言うのは
皆様方
ずるい人間になってほしくない
今既に無常を楽しんでいるのだから
無常に悪口をいってはいけない
生老病死に悪口をいってはいけない
「年取るのは嫌だ」「病気になるのは嫌だ」とか
変化する過程で
そういうものはなんでもかんでも起こる
「ものが生まれたら消えなくちゃいけない」
健康的な体ができたならば
健康状態は必ず消えなくてはならない
無常だから
ですから偽善者にならないで
私は
無常はいいんだけど、歳は取りたくない、とか
そういう
とてつもない、無知な話だけ捨ててください。
そこで、どこかで死後
永遠なところにいきたいのだと
テーラワーダ仏教では涅槃とかなんとかいいますけど
やっキリスト教のほうがありがたいのだと
なぜならば、キリスト教だったら
永遠な、なんといいますかあれは、
なんか楽園がありますねえ
そういうところが約束されているのだから
あれは嘘ですよ。考えてください
永遠のところだったら何も変化しませんから
永遠の楽園で例えばリンゴがあっても
リンゴがあってひっぱって食べたいでしょう
引っ張っても引っ張っても取れないんだから。永遠なんだから
そこで（リンゴが）落ちていたならば
落ちてはいないとは思いますが
落ちているリンゴは食べようと思っても食べられない
噛んでも噛んでもつぶれないのだから
永遠だから
ですから、永遠な場所はないのです
永遠というのは無の状態なのです
空の状態、無の状態
何もない状態
それ以外、永遠のところはない
まあ、そういうことで
無常を楽しんでください
無常を確実に実感して味わって
幸福を掴んでください
……たびに、心はリラックスするんですよ
イライラはしない
そこはだいたい、毎日経験しているんですね
例えばもう一つ例を申し上げると
例えば、カップがありますね
コーヒーカップにしても
紅茶のカップにしても
すごい高いものがありますね。一万、二万もする
カップがありますね。
そういうものを
高級デパートから買ってきたら
これはもう一生使えるのだと思っちゃうでしょう？
一時的に我々はそこで無常を
捨てちゃうんですね
これのカップは二万円でしたと
これはなんとかかんとかの会社で作ったものだと
それで一生使おうと思っちゃうんです
同時に紙コップも一つもってくるんですね
それで自分の子供が紙コップに
何か水をいれて、またそれは
買ってきた高価なカップに入れ替えちゃって
飲もうとしたところで割れちゃったと
紙カップは子供が
割っちゃっても捨てちゃってもなんてことはないんですね
全然
でも買ってきた二万円のカップが割れちゃったら
えらく怒るんですね
何ですかあれは？怒るのは
あれは一生使えると思ったからなんです
あれも紙カップと同じく
割れるんですよ
かえって紙カップは落としても割れませんね。
ですから
割れるものは割れるし
でも紙カップは割れちゃってもなんにも
心には
怒りも苦しみも悲しみもない
高価なカップが割れたところで
えらく激怒しちゃう
混乱しちゃう
やっと見つけたのよ、これは
もうないんだ、あのデパートにも、それで終わっちゃったんだから、というかもしれません。
1:00:17.600,1:00:18.120
それくらいだったら更に怒るのです
永遠にあってほしいと
この場合、永遠というのは短い距離ですけど
あればあるほど苦しいんです
ですからそれはまあ別に
そんなもんなんです、理屈というよりは
今も我々が常に苦しんでいるのは
いつでも永遠という概念が
どこかでウロウロしているからなんです
例えば人が自分で家を建てたとする
鉄筋で作ったならば
「これは２５年間使えるぞ」と思っちゃうんですね
そう思って家に入って
一週間目で仕事から家に帰ってくると
家が火事になっていたらこれはすごいショックなんです
なぜかというとそれは永遠にいるだろうと
自分がアパートを借りていたのだとしましょう
引っ越ししようとしているんだと
引っ越しの日にちを決めて
荷物を運んでいる
でも向こうにはまだ行ってない
このアパートにいるのはあと一日だけ
それで会社から帰ってくるとアパートが火事になっている
なんてことないでしょう？その場合は。
なぜかというとあと一日だけだから
今日はホテル止まってもいいのだと
だから、家が
自分が作った家が火事になったことにすごく悲しむのは
「一生、その家に住みます」と思ったからなんです
ですから苦しみ・悲しみは永遠の概念から出てくるのです
無常の概念から
すごく安らぎが生まれてくるのです
強烈な執着
バカみたいな喜びはない
あれはもう頭がおかしいのだからね
バカみたいによろこんでいるのは
そうじゃないんだけど楽しいことは楽しい
例えば自分がマイホームを作ったらならば
これはもう楽しいんですよ
無常だと
地震がおこっちゃったら、これはいくら（頑丈に）作ったとしても
全部、ガラクタになりますよと
とことん知ってる場合は
もう、なんてことはないのですよ
すごく、この
落ち着いて生活できるのです
そういうふうな働きで、無常というものを
認めると安らぎがあって
認めないと苦しみがある
無常を知るとそこに幸福があって
無常を知らないとそこに苦しみがある
だから結びついていますよ
永遠の概念と苦しみ
無常の概念と幸福・安らぎ
それは真実だから仏教は
永遠という言葉は全く使わない、それは嘘であると
無常の概念を使って
無常と幸福
無常とやすらぎ
一緒に語っているのです
今日書いた偈文でも
無常を知るならば、そこに清らかな道がある
清らかな状態と書いているのは
安らぎの状態、いわゆる涅槃の状態
解脱の心境なんです。
解脱したことになるのだと
「Esa maggo visuddhiyā」と
四番目に書いたのは
ですから
それほど難しいことではないのです
いとも簡単なんですが
なかなか人間は理解しない。それだけ
理解すれば楽しいのに
これは理解しない
世の中、例えば商売にしても
消耗品を売っている場合は
いつでも儲かっちゃうでしょう
なぜならば、いくら使っても
また使わなくてはならないから
例えば、食べ物やらたばこやら
使って終わるものだったら
いったん売ったら何年もかかる
モノだったらなかなか商売にならない
だから日本でも電気のほうが
大変進んでいましたから電気製品をたくさんつくって
買った冷蔵庫は
10年でも使えるんだから
だから冷蔵庫の会社が困っているんですね
だから何とか早く壊れるようにしちゃうし
あるいはなんか
わけのわからないいろいろくだらない何かをいれちゃって
新しく開発しましたと言って
人をだまして売っちゃうし
「もっと使い易くしました」と
勧誘をするでしょう
買ってきたところで使い易いどころか動きもしない
あまりにも
取扱説明書が分厚くて
どうやってスイッチ入れるかもわからないとか
そんなふうになっちゃうわけです。そこでなんでその人々が困っているかというと
何年間もものがもちますから
でも、肉屋さんはそんなに困りませんね
そんなに宣伝もしませんしね
新しく品質改良しましたとかね
みんな買って食べますから、それで終わりますから、次の日
また買わなくちゃいけないんだから
ですから、仕事の世界を見ても
やっ無常のほうがいいんですよ
例えば会社にしても
自分の仕事は安定しましたと
クビになる見込みも全くないのだと
思っちゃったらろくに仕事もしないでしょう
そうしたら仕事自体面白くなくなっちゃうんですね
「怠けてしまったらクビになるかもしれません」と
思っちゃうと元気で頑張る
努力がでてくるんです
ですから例えば公務員とか
官僚関係の仕事とか
選ぶのはもう怠け者なんですね
親たちはいつでも子供たちにね
「こういうことをしなさい、いい大学にはいって、いい仕事を選びなさい」と
というのはまあそういう意味で「怠けなさい」と
親は親の気持ちで
安定した生活をしてほしいのですね、子供には
ですからクビにならない仕事
があって欲しいというのは親の気持ちですけど
事実から見れば、才能ある子でしょう？
いい学校いって勉強するのは。
それは自殺行為なんですよ
才能ある子は決してああいうところにいってはいけないのです。
一番、危ない会社に入ったほうがいいのです
もうそろそろ一か月くらいで
倒れるだろうと
そこに行ったら自分の才能活かして
立ち直らせてみせると
すごい生き甲斐がありますよ
もう頑張らなくちゃいけないんだから、気持ちいいんです
私も教えた経験がありますけど
やっぱり生き甲斐があるのは
頭が悪い子に教えるときなんですね
なんとか頑張って、なんとか工夫して
この子にこれを理解させますと
ありとあらゆる工夫をしたところで理解してくれるでしょう？
「ああ、よかった」と思っちゃうんです
いっぺんに理解する人というのは全然おもしろくないのですね
一度言うと「はい。わかりました」「はい、終わり」と
それよりは「なんで、もう三回もいっているのに、わかってないんですか」と
ケンカしながら教えるのは
「教えている」という実感があるんだからね。
その時は怒ってしまったとしても、「教師は怒ってはいけません」と
それはもう
すごく落ち着いて、この子のあたまが
よく働いてくれるように、何か工夫をしなくてはいけないのだと
思ってやると
小さな、単純な教えであろうが
教える側も
ものすごい立派な人間になってしまうのです、教師として
ですからやっぱり無常がいいんですよ
どう見たっても
そうでなければ
世の中は成り立たない
ずっと変化しなければ
存在そのものも成り立たないんです
例えば年取ってくると
皆、悲しがってしまうのです
「子供たちが離れていきました」
「自分と一緒に生活しないのだ」と
「たまにでも顔をみせてくれないのだ」と
ああいう暗いことばっかり考えているんですね
体が弱くなったとか
ああだこうだとか
あれは無常を認めないからなんですね。
たとえば、子供が顔見せると
面白いんだけど
八十歳のおばあちゃんの子供というのは五十歳くらいだから
別に顔見たっても
全然、かわいくもなんともないんですね
仕事に疲れて疲れて
奥さんにいじめられて、また疲れて
そんな顔をみたとしても面白くないし
でも、なんとなく心の底で「自分が育てた時期」の
あのかわいい顔だけを覚えているのです
ですから会いに来ないとかね
実際に会いに来たとしてもそれほど面白くはない
ですから例えば年取ってくると
そうじゃなくて、例えば自分の体が弱い場合は
私はこう考えたほうがいいと思いますね
「もう八十年も生きましたから」
「そろそろ、十年もてばいいんだ」と
「まあ、五年もてばいいのだ」と
そういう風に思ったほうがいいし
世の中のことをみたら
「この世の中は私には関係ないのだ」と
経済問題とか子供たちが
いま会社が大変だと「それはいまあなた方が生きているんだから、
考えてください。私には関係ないのだ」と
「私にはあと十年もないのだ」と
「その十年楽しくいますよ」と
そう考えると、なんとも
悲しくはないんですね。
もうほんの少しだと
もうほんの少しだから
その分は元気で生きてられる
いつ死ぬかわかりませんよ、と思っちゃったら苦しいし
そういうことで無常そのものというのは
直接、安らぎに、幸福に
つながること
我々が苦しんでいるのは無常がわからないから
もう一つの言葉はドゥッカ（dukkha）なんですね
全てのものは無常であって
また苦（dukkha）であると
そこでちょっと問題がややこしくなるんですよ
全てのものが苦であると言ったら
どこに安らぎ、幸福がありますかと。
その「苦」というのは「苦しい」ということではなくて
同じく「無常」ということなんです
「実体は無い」ということでもあるし
「空しい」ということでもあります
「不完全」という意味もあります
大体、現代的にわかりやすいのは「不完全」であると
物事は
この不完全と無常は
ものすごく相性がいいんです
完全だったらそれで終わり
例えば、勉強が完全に終わってしまったら
もうやることないでしょうに
終っちゃうんです
ゴールに達したらもうやることなくなっちゃうんです
でも、世の中のものはずうっと
次の形、次の形へと変わっていくのです
一つの形が次の形に変わるのです
それは「不完全」だから
ですから年取ることは決して止めることはできない
もし、皆様方が今完全な
瞬間を体験したら
もう年を取らないかもしれません
でもあり得ないんですね
今、不完全だから体が変わってしまうのです。
どんな現象も完全ではない
ある一時的な現象なのです
例えば花が咲いたら
花は
（last productってなんですか？）
最終的な結果ではありません
現象の
花は変化の過程の
ある瞬間だけなんですね
花は実になっちゃうし
その中で種が生まれるし、まだ仕事がいっぱいあるのですよ
種になったら自分がどこかで
土の中に行かなくてはいけないし
それでも終わらないのですね。
また、芽がでなくてはいけないし。
また、次のこと、次のことと
一次的な現象だけ
だから
ずっとその状態であるのです
だからそれは、すごく高度な哲学なのです
今は「一時的」な
仮の現象であると
それは次の現象の準備だけなんです
例えば、米を持ってきましたと
米が最終的な段階だったら
そのまま放っておけばいいんですね
そうではないのです。
米は仮の状態で
米のままでは困るのだから
ご飯にならなくてはならないのです
米はごはんになるためにいる
準備状態
控室にいつでもいるんですよ、舞台に上がるために
そこで
米になったら米が舞台に上がっちゃえばいいのかというと、そうではないのです
米はいろんな人に食べられるための
準備段階にいるんです
食べられたらまた違う準備段階
それでもう最終状態
というのはないのです
物事に
我々にもないのです
赤ちゃんは
ちょっと大きい子供になるための準備段階
ちょっとした子供はもっと大きい子供になるための準備段階
どんどんその準備段階
我々も同じ準備段階にいるんですよ
今、最終的な目的にいるわけではないのです。
今ここに座っているのは、これが終わったら早く家に帰るという
気持ちです
こっちは家に帰ることを目的にして準備段階にいるのです
では、家に帰ったらほっとしますかというとそうではないのです
それは、次の事の準備段階
ということは、今は不完全な状態であると
準備、今は準備、次の
場面に
それだけ
ですから「不完全」という言葉を使うのです
それはどこまでいっても同じことなのです
「ああ、これで終わった」ということはないのです
ですから不完全であることを仏教で
dukkhaというのです。
ある面でそれも大変ですよ
準備というのはねえ。旅にでようと思ったら
旅は大したことないんだけど
旅の準備は大変だからねえ。外国旅行しようと思ったら
それは楽しいんだけど
準備は大変ですね
だから、その準備の面でみると大変ですよ
だからdukkha、苦しいというのです。
別に大胆な「苦しみ」という意味ではないのです。
それは哲学的に適当な言葉を選んだだけなのです。お釈迦様が
準備という目で見ればこれからの
現象、これからの状態を
考えなくてはいけない
また、かわいそうにその状態も次の状態の準備なんです
ですから
学校にいって勉強するのは
まあ、どこかで仕事するための準備なんです
仕事をするのは
やっ、給料もらうための準備なんです
給料もらうのは
食べたり生きたりするための準備なんです
食べたり生きたりしているのは仕事するための準備なんです
いつでも準備状態にいるんです
「準備中」と
我々も常にそういう看板が
掛かっていたほうがいいのです、「準備中」と
「商売中（営業中）」にはならないのです
それは不完全であると
「不完全」というのは「変化する事」だから
だから無常もdukkhaも
おなじこと
同じ意味
ですから、世の中は
dukkhaであると知っていたとしても同じことですよ。
まあ、準備ですからと。本番の前
でも全然本番というのはでてこない
いつでも準備
準備だからそんなに焦らなくたっていいでしょう
本番で間違ったら大変だからねえ
準備ですから焦ったり、泣いたり
する必要はない。間違ったらまた準備すればいいんだから
例えば、お客さんに接待するんだと思って
それをみんなお客さんもきて
それで食器が割れちゃったら
もう困るでしょう。食器がなくなっちゃうんだから
でも、準備段階で割れちゃったなら
また買ってくればいいんだから
ですから我々は常に準備段階にいるんだから
別にそんなに焦ったりする必要はない
何か間違ったらそれを直せばいい
それがdukkhaの意味なんですね。
この「五蘊（pañcakkhandha）」という言葉が仏教にありまして
体そのものがdukkhaであると
dukkhaの説明にその言葉がでてくるんですね。
色・受・想・行・識
ルーパ（rūpa）・ヴェーダナー（vedanā）・サンニャー（saññā）・サンカーラ（saṃskāra）・ヴィンニャーナ（viññāṇa）
体を五つの部分にわけているんです。仏教では。
そんなことは別に知らなくてもいいんですけどね
体には色という物体があります。
受という感覚の
世界がありまして
想というのは概念の世界であって
サンカーラ（行）という心の働きのようなものがありまして
ヴィンニャーナ（識）という心そのものがあります
そういうものは我々には巨大なものだと見えるのですね
そういうのも全部、準備段階であると
全部、まあ、変化していくのだと
心も変化する、感情も変化する
変化するんだから存在する
ですから、体の中にも
「苦・無常」しか（ない）
「魂・霊魂・永遠」という
概念はないのだと
あったら死んじゃうよ
とんでもないことになっちゃう
我々は六十年、八十年と
元気で生きていられるのは
魂がないからなのです
そんな永遠不滅のなにかがあったら
ややこしくて、ややこしくて、変化しないんだから
冗談じゃないんです
宗教家っていうのは科学を知りませんから
現代科学はそれほど立派な科学ではない
といろいろ言っていますけど
それはそうかもしれませんけど
やっぱり、なにか身体の中で
全く変化しない、頑固なものがあるならば
良いわけがないんです
仏教では、実体論は無し
魂はないんだと
ですから、「無我」というのです。
アナッター（anattā）
無我であると
なにか変化しないものがあったら
そこはもうすごく簡単に考えてください
私たちが例えばケーキを食べようとしているとしましょう
ケーキの中に
なにかこの
つくってる途中でプラスティックのなにか
例えば噛めない石でもいいだけど、一つ入っていたとしましょう
せっかくおいそうなケーキを口に入れたところで
噛みたくても噛めない何かがあったとして
気持ちいいんですかね
それで問題ですから
ご飯食べるときに
絶対消化しない変化しない何かを一緒に食べたとしたらどうなるんですかね
病気になってしまいます
物質からみたってそういうことで
もし我々の精神のなかでも
絶対変化しない何かがあったら
大変困るんですよ
あるわけない
例えば誰かに対して恨みやら
憎しみやらあって
永遠不滅なところに刻み込まれたらどうしますか
どれほど苦しいと思いますか？
そんなもんないんですよ！
ですから、怖がる必要はないんです
「霊魂ありますよ、魂ありますよ」と
皆ありがたくしゃべってますけど、あんなものがあったら
大変怖い話なんです
仏教というのは普通の宗教とはえらい違いますよ
いってることは
思想はまったく人間の思想・方法とはちがうのです
でも、仏教だけが真実を語っているんです
例えば
我々に悪い経験やら
嫌な気持ちやらいろんなものが頭に入っちゃって
それはいつか忘れちゃうでしょうに！
だから救われるんじゃないんですか？
なんでもかんでも覚えているならば
気持ちいいと思いますか？
たとえば、僕らはいろいろ工夫して
いろんな知識を頭に入れようとしているんです
で、大体簡単に
情報っていうのは頭の中に入っちゃうんです
皆さまがそんな話を聞くと
「ああ、ありがたい話だ」と思っちゃうでしょう？そうじゃないです
えらい苦しいんです
いろんな余計なものまで頭に入るんだから
余計な次元まで
理解しますから
もう苦しくてしょうがないんです
皆様方が本なんかを読んで
ああ、いい本だなとか簡単にいうでしょう
私はすごい混乱するんです
いい本どころじゃなくて
あの人がどんな気持ちで書いて、どこが間違っていて
ひとつひとつきめ細かく見えてしまいますから
すごい苦しいんです。
ですから、忘れるのが一番
ありがたいことなんです、消えることが
我々、嫌な人に出会っても
どこかで大失敗して大恥かいたとしても
一年、二年するとそれ忘れちゃうんです
もし覚えていると精神的に病気になっちゃうんです
もし、霊魂とか魂とか
なんかくだらないものがあったならば、それは永遠でしょう？
それに引っかかっていたら全然取れないのですから
それほど嫌なことはないんですよ
あるいは昔の人々は
思考方法がそれほど優れていなかったんだから
思った概念であって
真実ではないのです。未だにこの永遠の魂
体験した人、見つけた人はひとりもいないんです
無常というのはとことん見えますけど
（魂とは）一つの概念だけなんです
ですから、変化する現象しか存在しない
もう一つ例えを出すと提灯なんですね。日本の
すごいきれいな提灯あるでしょう？
例えば針金をもってきて
これくらいの針金もってきて
でっかく巻いたところで和紙をのせて
はったら
おおきなきれいな提灯がでてきて
あれはすごく大きくて
きれいですけど
それを置くためには結構大きな場所が必要なんです
えらい空間をとっちゃうんです
でもあれはひとつの現象なんです。
外してみたら
これくらいしか空間はとりません
ですからいつでも現象だけしかないのです
魂、提灯の魂はないのです
提灯みてください。
提灯の提灯たるものはどこにあるんですか？
和紙ですか？あるいは
電気やらろうそくを立てるあの部分ですか？
針金ですか、どちらでもないでしょう？
どちらでもほんの一部だけであって提灯そのものではないのです
提灯に提灯たるものはないのです
ですからここに私はいるんだけど
私たるものの実体はなし
変化することだけです
ですから現象だから変化する
だからaniccaといっても、dukkhaといっても
それからanatta だといっても
全く同じこと
その三つの一つを知る人が
完全たる解脱、完全たる幸福を
体験する
それは今すぐでもできる
死んでから涅槃に入るのではないのです
死ぬ前に涅槃に入るんです
死ぬ前にこの真実を掴まなくてはならないのです
死んでからはどこにいるのかわかりませんからね
例えば
こんな私のつまらない話を聞くのだから
死んでからは絶対、お坊さんには会わないようにとか
皆さま、いろいろ祈願までしているかもしれません
お坊さんがいないところに生まれ変わりたいとか
ですから、もし解脱を得たければ
やっぱり死ぬ前にやっておかなければならない
すごく簡単なものなんです
それほどややこしいものじゃないんです
とことん、永遠ではなくて
無常を認めますと
とことん自己観察することです
もう一度繰り返しいいますけど
無常を楽しみながら
無常に逆らうのは本当に犯罪行為ですよ
年取りたくないとか
変化してほしくないとか
あんなものは正気の人間がいうことではないのです
年取りたくないんだったら
生まれてくることもないんだから
ご飯食べたら年取るんだから、ご飯食べることはおいしいし
音楽が永遠であってほしいといったら音楽にならないんだから
音楽にしたっても
同じ自分が大好きな曲を
二十四時間回してみてください
どうなるんですか？気持ち悪くなって吐き気がするかもしれません
ですから同じものというのはいいことではないのです
日本の料理は世界で一番健康的で
大変いい料理だと
いい料理文化だといわれますから
一番いい特色というのは
いろんな種類が豊富ということなんです
品物というんですか
たくさんあることなんです
それはもう日本のご飯というのは
ご飯と
たくあんだけですと言ったら世界一にはなりませんよ
それだったら世界一つまらない食べ物だとなっちゃいますから
やっいろんな変化が
あってそこに幸福がある
それを認めることによって幸福があると
ですからいつでも
次の瞬間新しいのであると
次の瞬間はチャレンジであると
次の瞬間は私の計画通りには
おそらくいかないだろうと
その場で計画して
立ち向かわなくてはならないのだと
思ってみてください。そうするとえらい元気になるんです
家に帰ったらこういう風に話して
こういう風に会話して
と思ってもそうはならないんですね
たまにあるんですね。旦那さんがずっと仕事ばっかりして
夫婦の会話が無いんだと
それで奥さんもちょっと頭がおかしくなって
ケンカばっかりやっていて、誰かに言われるでしょう？
あんたは夫婦の会話が無いからなんですよ、もうちょっと会話でもしてください
それで旦那さんが会社の中で
頭で考えるんです
こういう風になんとか話してみますと
頭で計画立てるでしょう。特に男性というのは
すごい計画作るのが好きですから
で、計画立てたといっても、全然その計画が通用しません
奥さんが「うるさいから黙ってなさい」というんですよ
こっちはせっかく
会話しようと思っていたのに
仲良くしようと思ったのに
そうはいかない
いつでも次の瞬間は
どうなるかわからないよと
それで生きてほしいんです
それを嫌がってはいけない
例えば、いつ地震が起こるかわからないのだから
地震対策しているんじゃないんですか
次の瞬間わからないんだからね
だから無常こそ真理であって
幸福を掴むために真理を
掴まなくてはならない、ということです
なにか質問とかありますか？
無常とこの言葉三つ仏教の
基本
anicca・dukkha・anatta
覚るために何を理解するかというと
aniccaか、dukkhaか、anattaかどちらかなんですね
どっちに覚ったとしても同じこと
上下関係はないのです
レベルの高い覚りとか低い覚りとかは
ないんです
どちらかを体験するんです
もうひとつ例をいうならば
例えばこの
お母さんが自分の子供と遊んで、大変幸福を感じで楽しくいると
それでその状態が
ずっと続いてほしいと思っちゃうでしょう
その瞬間から子供はすごく嫌になっちゃうんです
自分が囚われてしまうのだと、束縛されるのだと
自由を失っちゃうんだと
その時でも
やっ、楽しいのはこの瞬間だけだと
そこで子供があまりにも甘えてくると
あんたはね、ちょっといい加減にしなさいと
あと五、六年たったら
偉そうに家の中でものを壊したり、
ケンカしたり障子を破ったりするではないかとかね
そのように先の嫌な状態でも
楽しく受け取る
と、決して不幸にはならないんです
例えば、自分の子がすごい乱暴を起こすことになったならば
「あれあれ、よく成長したもんだなあ」と
思っちゃえばいいんですよ
「まあ、そろそろ独立してはどうですかね」とか
家に入って
バカみたいに子供みたいにケンカしないで、もう大人だから
親のことは放っておけばどうですかと
大人になればどうですかと
言っちゃえばそれで終わりでしょうに
例えばまあ、中学生・高校生っていうのは
独立できるわけはないんだから
それでも、独立心はあるんだから、家庭内暴力を振るってしまいますよ
そんなにも一人で生きていたければ
一人でやればいいんじゃないかと
他の人よりも先に、はやく
それはさすが立派ですよと
家に帰ってこなくてもいいよ
言ってあげれば、それは本気で
いっちゃえばいい、それで終わるんですよ、問題は
子供はまあ
これでは親には効き目がないんだと
親は心配してくれないんだと知るし
自分も大人だったら大人らしくしなければならないんだ、とわかるし
あるいは
客観的に無執着の心で見ていると
やれやれ大きくなったもんだなあとかね
大人になったもんだなあとか
観察すれば大変楽しいでしょう
自分が抱っこして育てたものが
自分の二倍、背が高くなっちゃって
偉くなったのをこうやって外からみれば、それは楽しいんですよ
私の子だよとこうやると、気持ち悪くて子供にやられますから
そういう風に
無常というものを楽しむこと
どんな状態でも受け取ること
病気も堂々と受け取ること
他のものも、損だけ
ありがたいと、得は嫌ではなくて
損したら得するように
褒められたら次にけなされますよと
例えば日本ではよく使う手なんですけど
人を褒めちゃうんです。褒めたら
人はバカだからすぐのっちゃんですそれに。
褒められたから
じゃあ、これから頑張ろう、同じように褒められるために
必死に奴隷みたいに苦労するんです
あれはもう苦しいんですよ
褒められたら「ああそうか」と
「今度はよかったんだけど、次はわかりませんよ」と
無常だからね、いつでも
いいことばかりじゃないよといえば楽なんです
一度、本当においしいごはんを作ったところで
奥さんが大変ほめてもらったと
それで舞い上がってしまったら
同じおいしいものを毎日作ってあげますと
思っちゃったらもうやり切れないんですよ
神経質になって病院行きなんですよ
ですから「いえ、今回だけですよ」と
こんなことは毎日できないんだと
いくら褒めたとしても、といえば、それで問題終わり。
ですから褒められたら貶される
損したら得する、健康的だったら病気になる
病気の人には病気から立ち直るという現象がある
病気になるということは健康な人にある現象です。
別に病気の人は病気にならないんだから。病気だから
だからそういう順番になります。
で、すべては無常ということです
もう一部ありますけど、これはあの
ちょっと一言いいます。
次の瞬間どうなるかわからないだろう
と思ったほうがいいといったんですね
本当はそうなんですよ
家に帰ったら、例えば旦那さんが
奥さんが
「おかえりなさい」と気持ちよくいうかもしれませんし
腹が立って
ケンカ売るために箒でももって
いまは、箒はないんだけど
漫画だったら箒をもってますけど――もっているかもしれませんし
次の瞬間はわからないと。
いったほうがワクワクしていいんだけど
だからといって、なんでもかんでも
でたらめに無常ではないのです
無常だからなんでもかんでも
でたらめいい加減に無常ということではないのです
その中に法則があるんです
それは違う話になりますけど
たとえば
リンゴの種を植えたんだと
ちょっとした10cmくらい木が伸びたんだと
で、夜寝て
まあ、やっぱりあれは無常だから
もしかしたら明日の朝リンゴの実が出ているかもしれません、と
思っちゃうとそれはばかばかしいんですね。
木が無常だから毎日変化する
いつか花が咲いて実が実る
でも、10cm伸びただけで、
葉っぱが四枚くらいあるだけで
実るわけにはいきません
順番というのがあるんです
順番があるんだけど、そのなかにも無常があるんです
順番にならないかもしれません
実らないかもしれません、花が咲かないかもしれません
木が虫に食われるかもしれません
私たちも順番に変化しますけど
決して、赤ちゃんはいきなり
青年にはならない
それは順番があり、因果法則で
説明するものなんです
無常であっても、でたらめではないんだと